dans le château de chambord
peuplée d'étranges statues vivantes le
nouveau maître s'appelle jacques demy le
réalisateur des demoiselles de rochefort
et des parapluies de cherbourg vient de
s'y installer pour tourner sa nouvelle
comédie musicale peau d'âne tiré du
conte de perrault
sous une chaleur torride ce film est
avant tout la réunion pour la première
fois le jean marais et catherine deneuve
c'est la rencontre de deux monstres
sacrés de deux époques du cinéma et
votre personnage et bien c'est le père
de la princesse effet ne lève et peau
d'âne et c'est un père qui décide
d'épouser sa fille et qui devient
mauvais sa fille c'est curieux points
contre d'enfants parce que ça comme de
perrault ça c'est curieux mais me tous
les contes d'enfants sont assez connus
qu'elle m'aimait vous beaucoup
bien ou mal j'ai décidé de vous épousez
catherine deneuve baysse que quand vous
avez joué un personnage qui a une
signification profonde comme des stones
ans ça ne vous fait pas l'effet d'être
un peu léger un peu superficielle de
tourner pour dames
un coup d'essai superficiel ah non je
trouve que c'est de quoi très très très
mystérieux très profond très beaucoup
moins pour les enfants même ce qu'est ce
qu'on ne pourrait le croire et surtout
pas d'armes
c'est un conte un peu à peu ce qu'est ce
que vous avez l'impression que c'est un
film pour enfants jean-louis quand même
beaucoup mais ça c'est une grande joie
parce qu'ils pensent beaucoup pour vous
c'est votre premier film commence à oui
c'est le premier film je crois où je
pouvoir mais aussi